analyzing your unstructured data such as
images and freeform text has long had to
take place outside of your data
warehouse and requiring complex machine
learning expertise in order to draw out
insights however bigquery and vertex AI
are changing that in this video we'll
show you how you can use pre-trained
machine learning capabilities of vertex
AI directly within bigquery using its
inference engine you'll see a demo of
how you can analyze and enhance
unstructured data all with the
familiarity of SQL before we jump into a
demo let's walk through an overview of
the capabilities built into bigquery
that enable you to analyze unstructured
data in this way
firstly bigquery is Google Cloud's data
warehouse that allows you to not only
store and analyze structured data but
also unstructured data like freeform
text and even images via object tables
that extend out to data in Google Cloud
Storage
bigquery is highly scalable so no matter
how much data you have bigquery can
store it and help you analyze it
now when it comes to extracting meaning
and gaining insights from your
unstructured data it's common to use
machine learning models to analyze this
kind of data vertex AI offers several
pre-trained machine learning models
targeting various use cases
the three we will be highlighting for
analyzing unstructured data in bigquery
are the vision API for tasks such as
object detection OCR and labeling and
images
the natural language API for extracting
entities classification or performing
sentiment analysis on freeform text
and the translation API for language
detection and translation of freeform
text for over 100 languages
what ties the two together is bigquery
ML and more specifically bigquery ml's
inference engine which allows you to
connect and run predictions against
vertex ai's pre-trained ml models
when called by the inference engine the
pre-trained models return Json responses
that can be stored and analyzed at scale
in bigquery
okay let's head over to the demo and
analyze some unstructured data I'm
starting here in my colab notebook a
hosted Jupiter notebook that can connect
to my gcp project and run commands code
and queries
it's linked in the description so you
can make a copy and follow along
we have a set of classic movie poster
images that we'd like to analyze first
by detecting and translating text
present on the posters and then running
sentiment analysis on reviews for those
movies
the first part of the notebook runs you
through several steps for configuring
The Notebook environment such as
importing libraries and setting up
variables as well as setting up your gcp
project including authenticating
choosing your project enabling apis and
more you can read about in The Notebook
the next thing you'll do is create a
bigquery data set and populate an object
table
the object table provides a structured
record interface for the movie poster
images that we have stored in Google
Cloud Storage
once created it contains metadata such
as the uri's content type and size of
the posters
a quick note as I mentioned before
you'll also be analyzing free form text
of associated movie reviews on IMDb this
data set is actually available publicly
in bigquery and this type of
unstructured data is stored entirely in
a bigquery table and doesn't require an
object table
all right now that we have our data
let's start performing OCR on the movie
poster images to pull out the text
first you need to create the vision AI
remote model which essentially enables
the ml.annotate image function a
connection to the vision API from
bigquery
this model setup is one time and then
you can continue to use it in your
project
now you'll use that function in a SQL
statement to run the text detection
feature over the entire object table of
images and return the Json formatted
results of the ml API alongside the
other Columns of the table
querying that table you can see the
results that were provided by the vision
API for each poster
now the movie titles are in several
languages and so next you'll translate
the text to English so that you can join
them with the English language IMDb
reviews
for this you'll create the remote model
for the translation API which allows you
to use ml.translate to both detect the
language of the results from the OCR
step and then translate it to English
here's a sampling of the results where
the original language was detected as
French and then translated to English
finally you'll create the remote model
for the natural language API and then
use the ml.understand text feature to
run sentiment analysis of reviews from
the IMDb public data set in bigquery
your first query will run sentiment
analysis on the reviews for one of the
titles from the results of the previous
steps The Lost World which was released
in 1925.
the response from the NLP API provides a
sentiment score from clearly negative to
clearly positive and neutral in between
in the final query you'll use sentiment
analysis to compare the IMDb reviews for
other movies released in 1925 against
reviews for the last World
analyzing the average sentiment scores
you can see that Sally of the sawdust
eeked out in first place
using the vertex AI pre-trained ml
models via bqml's inference engine is
really a game changer for drawing
insights from unstructured data at scale
without complex code or needing ml
expertise or ever leaving your data
warehouse
try it for yourself access the collab
notebook and check out the documentation
both are linked in the description below